George starts herself this hour in
Arizona hey George how are you I'm doing
well thank you Dave thank you for taking
my call and thank you for everything you
do because of that I've been debt-free
for two years now good for you my
question thank you I I have a small HVAC
business here and you know my view on
money and credit cards has totally
changed since listening to use logic
knotch having in credit cards and I run
my business completely debt-free when I
talk to some friends or family about you
know spending in my business when I buy
parts and materials I immediately pay it
with a debit card and people think I'm
crazy for not using a credit card to
earn the dollar points or cash back
towards my question is what's a good
response to tell them why I don't care
to even have a credit card to earn those
points that I could be getting well to
start with you need to understand that
there's not a response that's going to
make them be okay and so you've just got
to understand you're gonna do what
you're gonna do and there's always gonna
be some people that are not okay you
know those convinced against their will
or of the same opinion still my
grandmother used to say and so you you
just really can't talk someone into not
being stupid
they can decide to investigate and
understand something but the chances of
them saying well you're an idiot for not
getting all your miles and you having a
response that changes that is probably
not there now if you have a question in
your mind then we can address that but
you know the bottom line is is that
heating and air companies that run a
bunch of debt and misbehave with the
handling of their expenses fail at a
much higher rate than people who run no
debt and who are very careful with
their expenses that's the real answer
and there's not ever been a millionaire
ever that I met with that says you know
I made all my money on those airline
miles
that was my breakthrough financially but
almost all the millionaires that when we
did the largest survey of millionaires
ever done over 10,000 North American
millionaires surveyed almost all of them
in the 80 percentile range said they
don't use consumer debt and the biggest
mistake they ever made in their life was
back when they were younger and did and
that they correlate becoming wealthy
with avoiding debt none of them said oh
man I'm really glad I ran all my
expenses through a credit card so I
could get airline miles because it
changed my life none of them said that
it doesn't make much sense to me I being
debt-free for two years it's the most
exhilarating feeling yeah I mean it's so
you know the rule of thumb is if broke
people are making fun of your financial
plan you're right on track
it's like fat people making fun of your
diet you know yeah it's not the broke
people it's just people that have money
but still they ask me that may think I'm
crazy which is fine you know I've been
crazy for a long time it's working for
me okay all right thanks David that's
all I needed
amen appreciate the appreciate the call
you're just not gonna get people to
behave or to understand all the time
it's just not gonna happen
so there you go